describe cada fracción con denominador
de 10 tenemos aquí dos fracciones tres
quintos y siete medios si queremos tomar
los denominadores que son 5 y 2 y
cambiarlos tal que sean denominador
común de 10 así que vamos a iniciar con
tres quintos bueno aquí tenemos un
rectángulo este rectángulo representa un
entero y aquí podemos visualizar lo que
estamos haciendo para simbolizar tres
quintos de este entero vamos a dividir
al entero en quintas partes es decir en
cinco pedazos iguales así que a este
entero lo voy a dividir en cinco partes
iguales deben tener el mismo tamaño
entonces ya tenemos aquí cinco quintos
y para mostrar tres quintos
necesitamos sombrear tres de esos cinco
pedazos y así quedan representados tres
quintos pero hemos decidido cambiar los
quintos por décimos es decir queremos un
nuevo denominador de 10 entonces tanto
para cambiar esta fracción así como a
este entero divido en quintos e hacer lo
que represente decimos lo que haremos es
dividir cada quinta parte a la mitad y
de esta forma vamos a duplicar la
cantidad de pedazos entonces partimos
estos cinco quintos por mitad y así
obtenemos en lugar de cinco pedazos en
lugar de cinco pedazos iguales diez
pedazos iguales así que bueno contamos
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve diez puedes ver que
encontramos una manera de tener decimos
sin cambiar la cantidad representada
porque observa aquí como sigue sombreada
la misma cantidad pero ahora lo tenemos
en términos de decimos así que bueno
por lo tanto nuestro denominador fue
duplicado o lo que es lo mismo lo
multiplicamos por 2 ahora observe que le
pasó el numerador en lugar de tener tres
pedazos sombreados ahora tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 también en el numerador tenemos el
doble de cantidad también en el
denominador multiplicamos por 2 y esto
sucede porque si duplicamos todos los
pedazos también estaríamos duplicando
los pedazos sombreados observa como a
cada pedazo sombreado también lo estamos
partiendo en dos pedazos iguales por lo
que también tenemos el doble de cantidad
de piezas sombreadas entonces tres
quintos pueden escribirse como seis
décimos es decir tres quintos es igual a
seis décimos representan la misma
cantidad y observa como no cambio la
fracción no cambio la cantidad de
pedazos sombreados esto representa tanto
a tres quintos como a seis décimos lo
único que cambió fue el denominador a
este lo escribimos de manera distinta
así que como es otra manera de escribir
tres quintos
bueno pues tres quintos puede escribirse
6 decimos ahora seguimos con el
siguiente ejemplo 7 medios muy bien aquí
nuevamente queremos que el denominador
sea 10
para resolver esto podemos hacerlo de
dos maneras podemos dibujarlo como aquí
o podemos utilizar el método que usamos
aquí arriba en este ejemplo usar este
patrón para pasar de medios a destinos
observa aquí como para pasar de 5 a 10
tuvimos que duplicar al 5 es decir
tuvimos que multiplicarlo por 2 ahora
usando ese mismo razonamiento para pasar
de medios a décimas
tendríamos que multiplicar cada una de
estas piezas por 5 lo que estaría
pasando en el fondo es que a cada uno de
estos dos pedazos lo estaríamos
dividiendo en cinco pedazos de igual
tamaño así que para pasar de 2 a 10
multiplicamos por 5 y justo como lo
hicimos en el ejemplo anterior si yo
multiplico al denominador por un número
también debo multiplicar el numerador
por ese mismo número
y eso es porque en el numerador están
representados los pedazos sombreados y a
estos pedazos sombreados también los
estamos dividiendo en cinco pedazos de
igual tamaño por eso lo que hagas en el
denominador también debes hacerlo en el
numerador si estamos multiplicando al
denominador por 5 también multiplicamos
el numerador por 5
entonces multiplicamos al 7 por 5 eso es
igual a 35 35 décimos es igual a 7
medios entonces bueno recapitulando para
cambiar estas dos fracciones tal que
tengan denominador común de 10 obtenemos
que tres quintos se convierten en seis
décimos y siete medios se convierte en
35 decimos y terminamos